[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ses points de vue ravi de
vous retrouver pour notre rendez vous
quotidien avec quatre sujets sur
laquelle nous allons échanger des
opinions de préférence contradictoires
emmanuel macron et et hier à new york
devant l'assemblée générale des nations
unies très motivés très inspiré le jeune
public serait-il plus à l'aise à new
york à paris où la rentrée est quand
même difficile on en parlera et puis
nous évoquerons aussi cette décision de
la cour d'appel de paris de réduire de
deux à un million d'euros mais un
million d'euros quand même la saisie
réalisée par la justice sur les comptes
du rassemblement national
ou plus exactement sur la subvention qui
leur est destinée en prévision d'une
éventuelle condamnation pour emploi
fictif au sein de ce parti
nous parlerons aussi de la mairie de
paris edouard philippe le premier
ministre n'est pas candidat à ce poste
mais y'en a qui l'hiver est bien ce que
edouard philippe ferait un bon maire on
en parlera et puis on parlera d'eric
zemmour laurent ruquier finalement ne
l'invitera pas samedi prochain pour son
émission hebdomadaire sur france 2 est
ce que c'est le le droit normal d'un
animateur de choisir ses invités ou bien
est ce que finalement compte tenu de
l'importance d'eric zemmour il devrait
l'inviter au nom d'une forme de
d'indépendance ou d'objectivité du
service public
nous allons parler de tous ces sujets
avec nos quatre invités bonsoir anne
sophie beauvais vous êtes la directrice
générale de sciences po alumni les
sessions des anciens élèves de sciences
po rédactrice en chef du magazine
emile qui est le magazine justement des
anciens de sciences po qui met en
couverture dans sa dernière livraison
notre consoeur léa salamé et votre
dernier livre on s'était dit rendez vous
dans vingt ans a été publié chez plon
bonsoir génie bastié vous êtes
journaliste au figaro à la rubrique
débats et opinion vous êtes aussi
rédactrice en chef politique de la revue
limite votre dernier livre vient de
sortir il ya quelques heures on peut
presque dire ça s'appelle le port il
maniait tendance anti servandoni
l'époque en sortit une sorte vendredi
mais c'est comme on en parle déjà
beaucoup
on a l'impression qu'il est déjà en
livrerez grande et voilà on peut le pré
commander sur amazon publicité gratuite
et vous êtes une réflexion sur le
l'opération balances ton port et tous
ses impacts sur les relations hommes
femmes
et c'est publié aux éditions du cerf
gaspard cancer est là aussi bon soir on
est ravis de vous accueillir un point de
vue vous avez été le responsable de la
communication de françois hollande quand
il était président de la république vous
avez co fondé une agence de conseil en
communication vous est ce aussi l'auteur
de la politique est un sport de combat
chez fayard et j'ai presque fini vous
êtes le fondateur de parisienne parisien
c'est en juin dernier est un
rassemblement de parisiens vous êtes
pour la suppression du périphérique wii
et vous êtes presque candidat à la
mairie de paris
on en reparlera on en reparlera très
bientôt girard est là aussi bon soit
renault vous êtes le chroniqueur
international du figaro on vous retrouve
tous les mardis matin dans les pages de
cet excellent quotidien est votre
dernier livre qu'elle diplomatie pour la
france prendre les réalités telles
qu'elles sont a été publié aux éditions
du cerf on commence donc avec cette ce
discours très remarqué des manuels
macron c'était hier à l'assemblée
générale des nations unies à new york le
président il ya défendu avec beaucoup de
force
le multilatéralisme et comme disaient
les jeunes comme diraient les jeunes ils
étaient a donc regardé que défendre la
coopération et le multilatéralisme peut
ne plus être à la mode
alors ne soyons pas à la mode parce que
nous le devons à ceux qui nous ont
permis d'être assis là parce que
n'oubliez jamais que les génocides qui
ont fait que vous êtes là aujourd'hui
il était nourri par les discours auquel
nous nous invitions engageons-nous
clairement et soyons tous est tout aussi
clair concret et cohérent il y a urgence
ne signons plus d'accords commerciaux
avec les puissances qui ne respectent
pas l'accord de paris alors tout au long
de ce discours c'était une critique en
creux de donald trump qu'il fallait
entendre
renaud girard c'était du grand macron
hier je sais pas s'il va pouvoir
tenez
les promesses de son discours c'est à
dire de plus signé d'accords commerciaux
avec des états unis ça va être difficile
d'autant plus que pour le moment la
france quand même aux billes puisque les
entreprises françaises comme peu jour
comme total on obéit au doigt et à
l'oeil aux américains puisqu'ils se sont
retirés de l'iran c'est remake aux
affaires certes la france l'angleterre
l'allemagne la russie et la chine se
sont réunis à laon pour essayer de
trouver une sorte de chambre de
compensation de faire une sorte de troc
qui évite de passer par tout système
monétaire soumis au delà pour continuer
faire du commerce avec les rangs pour
que l'iran puisse exporter son pétrole
s'est pas encore mise en place mais je
ne sais pas je me demande si le discours
des manuels mâcon n'a pas un petit peu
dépassé
c'est possibilité il a raison de
défendre le multilatéralisme ce qu'ont
fait les américains sur l'iran est
indéfendable parce que c'est quand même
peu c'est est ce que tu as des as
qu'eric avait négocié cet accord
nucléaire du 14 juillet 2015 at-on en
avant guingamp va pas décider de se
retirer ce recrutement alors que c'était
ça avait été transformée sans une
résolution du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu a lancé une campagne de boycott je
vous coupe la parole quelques instants
on verra mais on reviendra vers vous
bien sûr ta voix pour dire chers
internautes que vous donnez votre avis
vous votez vous pose la question sur
twitter selon vous emmanuel macron at il
été convaincant à la tribune de l'onu
vous êtes 36% à répondre oui 64% à
répondre non un petit commentaire
un premier commentaire celui de vincent
qui a pris le discours du président
comme un acte de trahison pour lui il a
tiré sur son propre camp sans doute
voulait-il parler du camp occidental
on parlait du discours sur le fond
gaspard gods et remet sur la forme on a
vu un emmanuel macron en pleine forme
conquérants peut-être un peu arrogant je
ne sais pas vous donnerez votre avis si
vous voulez ça contraste assez fortement
avec une rentrée qui comme un peu
laborieuses à paris c'est plus facile
pour un président d'être à l'étranger
que dans son pays vous qu'elle essayait
d'hollande
ce qui est intéressant c'est que les
quinquennat se succèdent mais ce
répète voir se reproduisent et comme ses
prédécesseurs
emmanuel macron cherche peut être un
échappatoire dans les affaires
diplomatiques internationales quand
l'orage commence à gronder en france
c'est ce que nicolas sarkozy avait fait
il était d'ailleurs persuadé que son
action pour sauver la france en cas de
la crise de 2008 lui permettrait d'être
réduits il a eu tort
françois hollande a beaucoup misé sur
l'international notamment pour arriver à
la conclusion de l'accord sur deux sur
le climat de paris mais aussi avec un
accord sur les gens dont je viens de
parler ça n'a pas empêché d'être empêché
d'être candidat
et là emmanuel macron alors qu'il est
d'abord attendu sur les questions
nationales aussi mise beaucoup sur
l'international
son discours il et il est bon parce
qu'en face ils subissent bas pour les
valeurs de la france au multilatéralisme
face à un treuil qui sort de toutes les
négociations internationales
après c'est vrai qu'on se demande un peu
à quoi sert l'assemblée générale des
nations-unies aujourd'hui en l'absence
du président chinois du premier ministre
indien
quand même hein c'est on est vraiment
sûr avec un trump qui est là quelques
minutes et qui passe un peu en coup de
vent pour écraser de son talent l'onu
donc c'est bien que président se bat
mais malheureusement je crains que tout
ça reste un peu son effet vous parlez
d'un trump lui alors il s'y a carrément
de la tribune des nations unies pour
défendre son bilan on a l'impression
qu'ils parlent plus à ses électeurs dans
la perspective des élections de
mi-mandat korhogo de représentants des
pays rassemblent rassemblés à
l'assemblée générale
écouter juste qu'elle quelques secondes
le moment où il défend son bilan et il
provoque des réactions on va dire
contrastée
tous les spectacles
voilà petit commentaire en passant pour
un homme que certains disent être fou je
trouve que il tient c'est bien marrante
mais c'est pas le sujet d'aujourd'hui
génie bastié c'est plus facile de deux
d'essayer de changer le monde que de
réformer son propre pays quand on est un
président français
moi je trouve que le discours de macron
il est un peu il est très très joli sur
le papier mais il a un peu creuse c'est
à dire que au moins aimé enfin au moins
donne un train le moment est cohérent
avec son 10e en transition discours et
ses actes et je trouve que le fin mot
dire l'invocation du multilatéralisme
comme ça quand comment un grand discours
un peu un peu creux
ma part et voilà un peu un peu ridicule
et c'est un peu incantatoire
voilà ce qu'un parent quant à thouars et
qu'on va dire le discours de trump c'est
chacun à chaque pays devrait défendre
son propre intérêt et même et macro
devrait reprendre ce discours en disant
moi je défends l'intérêt de la france
et voilà pourquoi expliquer ses
décisions la lumière de cet intérêt de
la france
là on a l'impression qu'il veut défendre
un espèce d'intérêt général supra
nationale dont on voit mal comment il
pourrait s'appliquer en dehors de la
question du climat
la question du climat encore une fois il
a reçu d'ailleurs j'ai vu l'onu lui a
remis le titre de champion de la terre
mais macron bon c'est un titre
honorifique mais on voit pas ça ça
semble un peu indécent un mois après la
démission de nicolas hulot qui a bien
justifier enfin ajusté tri souligné que
même le coup on n'a pas fait grand chose
pour le climat depuis le début de son
quinquennat
d'ailleurs la com 21 c'était françois
hollande et fabius et ségolène royal
mettait pas emmanuel macron crème
l'accord de paris qui défend aujourd'hui
certes donc je trouve ça un peu voilà
étrange on ne voit pas en fait les
contours de cette de ce multilatéralise
qui prétend défendre
elle se fit beauvais donc j'ai dit pas
s'il disait emmanuel macron été désigné
champion de la terre certains le
soupçonnent d'être peut-être un peu pris
par lui brise cette toute puissance
qu'on a au sommet ça risque de ne pas
arranger les choses
oui enfin en même temps je trouve qu'il
était dans dans son rôle il défend des
les valeurs universelles de la france et
son discours avait une forme de
cohérence et défendent le
multilatéralisme face à un trump c'était
2-2 discours qui s'affrontaient et c'est
enfin renaud girard lui dirai mieux que
moi mais je crois que c'est quand même
le débat actuel dans ce nouvel ordre du
monde se pose quand même en c'est en ces
termes là mais c'est vrai qu'ils étaient
presque al'inverse l'un et l'autre face
à cette assemblée parce que quel est le
bilan des mains des manuels macro si
effectivement pour se présenter face à
cette organisation internationale si on
regarde ce qui se passe en france sont
lisses de l'écologie effectivement vient
de vient de claquer la porte donc on
peut toujours s'interroger sur sa
capacité à se prononcer sur des sujets
comme celui ci est l inverse trump avait
quelque part un très bon bilan à la tête
des états unis de manière très concrète
on peut dire que l'économie américaine
fonctionne plutôt bien il se présente
avec un bon bilan de ce point de vue là
la croissance américaine est très forte
à 4% le taux de chômage croît n'a jamais
été aussi bas depuis 55 ans donc c'est
vrai qu'on avait deux présidents qui
s'affrontaient mais sans doute avec un
bilan pour le faire chez eux très très
différents girard 30 macron 1 0 c'est à
dire que ce que ce que vous nous aidiez
très important je pense effectivement il
peut pas y avoir de grandes politique
étrangère peut pas y avoir deux discours
audible de la france la france est
attendu par toutes les puissances du
monde parce que elle a toujours quelque
chose la france du général de gaulle a
vraiment fait progresser les choses sur
par exemple sur la guerre du vietnam sur
le privilège exorbitant du dollar etc
etc
la france est à dont ils la voient la
france est attendue elle elle est
respectée où elle était en tout cas très
respecté à travers le monde mais pour
qu'elle soit entendue
il faut que la france souhaite
exemplaire chez elle c'est à dire qu'on
ne peut pas écouter on ne peut pas
admirer un président même avec les
meilleures idées du monde si c'est lui
c'est un petit peu la pagaille c'est la
pagaille dans son éducation nationale
c'est la pagaille dans ses comptes
publics
c'est là c'est la pagaille dans ses lois
sociales etc
donc en fait on ne peut être entendu que
si on est exemplaire chez soi et c'était
d'ailleurs le cas il faut vous souvenir
que de gaulle avant de faire sa grande
politique étrangère eh bien il ad'abord
rétabli l'ordre chez lui c'est à dire
qu'il a mis les finances publiques au
nord et lamy
il a fini d'algérie etc c'est seulement
une fois que la france était
fonctionnait bien
les institutions fonctionnent et bien
qu'ils ont qu'ensuite il est passé à son
grand discours de politique étrangère le
problème effectivement c'est tout à fait
très tout à fait bien souligner c'est à
dire qu'il ya ba trompe il a dit america
first bah oui oui ça a l'air de marcher
pour l'économie ça marche suffisamment
pour la corée enfin il est en train
d'obtenir quelque chose encore et quand
même il est il a obtenu la limitation de
l'immigration illégale en mai mais il
est contre le multilatéralisme et il a
tort d'être continuité avis parce que le
multilatéralisme a été fait par ses
prédécesseurs cet effet par roosevelt
c'est quelque chose de très important
pour la stabilité et la paix du monde
mais macron et n'a pas une position
forte pour défendre ce bon principe du
multi la tonne alors le dernier mot
restera à nos internautes qui sont assez
partagés 1 yohan sur lefigaro.fr nous
dit macron s'est montré convaincant et
c'est justement le problème car il est
bon à l'international mais au niveau
national ils n'arrivent pas à se faire
comprendre
bon à l'international ce n'était pas
l'avis de maxandre qui dit il en a fait
beaucoup trop comme un comédien au
théâtre ce qui gâche sa crédibilité et
mick déclare insulter la france et les
français seulement quand il est à
l'étranger c'est devenu une habitude
alors ça semble être une allusion à une
incise dans le discours présidentiel où
il disait que la france avait des choses
à se reprocher voilà il m'a semblé que
c'était tellement vague que l on avait
du mal à prendre ça pour une forme
d'auto culpabilité mais chacun jugera
comme il l'entend un autre sujet qui n'a
rien à voir encore que c'est marine le
pen qui a relevé cette phrase du
président de la république sur une une
de ce qu'elle considère comme être une
forme d'auto culpabilisation le
rassemblement national
avait fait l'objet d'une saisie
conservatoire de 2 millions d'euros sur
sa subvention publique en prévision
d'une éventuelle condamnation par la
justice pour cause d'emplois fictifs
dans ce parti sauf que la cour d'appel
de paris a décidé que finalement ce
serait pas 2 millions d'euros qui serait
prélevée à titre préventif mais un
million sébastien chenu le porte parole
du rassemblement national est plutôt
heureux de cette décision mais il en
profite pour attaquer clairement les
juges qui en sont à l'origine
avant d'être une victoire ou une demi
victoire pour le rassemblement national
c'est avant tout un désaveu d'une
décision politique prise par deux juges
politisés
les juges tpo et vendre une beck qui ont
vu leurs décisions outrancière leur
ordonnance outrancière est exagéré
contestée par la cour d'appel et par
l'appel que nous avions formulées alors
cette saisie quand on peut dire qu'elle
n'est pas très ordinaire arrive à côté
d'une autre france yves judiciaire une
expertise psychiatrique avait été
demandé à marine le pen dans une autre
affaire et celle ci en profite
ou en tout cas y voit clairement une
forme d'acharnement politique de la
justice
écoutez la c'était dimanche dernier ce
qui compte ce ne sont pas les faits et
vous l'avez bien compris
mais la personnalité que l'on veut
atteindre ou les opinions de ceux à qui
on les reproches tic moi quels sont vos
opinions et je vous dirai si on vous
poursuit ou même si vous êtes coupable a
de ce fait beauvais il ya une espèce
d'acharnement judiciaire contre le
rassemblement national ou une justice
politique un acharnement judiciaire je
sais pas une justice politique moi je
pars un peu du principe que dès
l'instant que la justice s'intéresse aux
politiques ça devient presque une
justice politique parce qu'on ne peut
pas être juge et du jour au lendemain
extraire complètement ses opinions d'une
un processus après qui s'enclenche moi
je le pense c'est valable dans des
opinions enfin c'est valable dans des
affaires politiques comme c'est valable
dans d'autres affaires un juge mais ne
vient pas de nulle part il vient jamais
nulle part et je pense que
l'honnêteté veut qu'on le dise à un
moment donné donc l'appréciation est
toujours malgré tout un peu biaisé et
voilà et en plus de ça je pense que
quand vous êtes juge
vous savez bien que les décisions que
vous allez prendre vont transformer le
jeu politique on l'a vu avec françois
fillon le voilà avec marine le pen donc
vous pouvez pas prendre comme ça des
décisions sans être un peu traversé par
des questionnements et quelque part par
votre propre opinion votre propre passé
donc j'ai tendance à dire c'est pas une
justice politique elle n'est pas là pour
faire la la la chasse et voilà mais on
peut pas dire que la justice s'intéresse
aux politiques encore une fois sans 100
kg est une espèce de d'interrogation sur
ce sur ce sujet là mais moi la question
que je me pose aussi c'est ce système
confiscatoire je trouve ça étrange enfin
cesser je suis pas juriste non plus mais
en fait vous avez donc une mesure qui
permet de vous confisquer avant même que
l'infraction soit reconnue alors je sais
pas je me dis que dans un braquage en
fait je comprends que la berline qui est
servi au braquage on l'a confisqué je
comprends que les lingots d'or qui
étaient volés dans le braquage en les
confisquent mais là j'ai un petit peu de
mal sur cet exercice de projection et je
m'interroge sur cette justice pénale
financière qui paraît-il de plus en plus
cela le phénomène est assez récent se
fait quatre cinq ans confisqué comme ça
préalablement à l'instruction et à la
déclaration de l'infraction
une somme qui est quand même
effectivement pas complètement
négligeable même si elle a été rabaissé
1 million voilà génipa ci est ce que
tous les responsables politiques contre
sont traités de cette façon ou bien est
ce qu il ya un traitement particulier
pour le rassemblement national selon
vous sur les emplois fictifs non puisque
vous rappeler que françois fillon se
faire prendre à la présidentielle donc
ce n'est pas les socialistes aussi à
l'époque soit toujours se distingue deux
affaires la famille fictif un avis c'est
le déroulement normal de la justice est
en effet s'il ya eu triche en tout cas
vol d'une partie de l'argent public ça
doit être puni par la loi
en revanche pas répété sur cette affaire
quand même avec le parlement mais moi ce
qui me scandalise vraiment c'est la
première affaire c'est le marine le pen
et donc est convoqué pour une expertise
psychiatrique où il ya une plainte ou
les juges donc d'essayer met en oeuvre
une procédure judiciaire
pourquoi parce qu'elle a tweeté des
images de l'état islamique mettant en
scène des égorgements je trouve que
c'est enfin voila c'est absolument
scandaleux de la poursuivre pour ça
comme si elle avait fait une propagation
de la haine alors que c'est une
d'ailleurs pas là pour forte de
complicité complice effectivement alors
elle a montré le réel pour sensibiliser
les ans les gens saison on peut trouver
évidemment ça indécent
on peut la critiquer et dire que c'est
pas digne d'une pub de responsables
politiques de s'abaisser à ce genre de
pratiques mais je trouve ça scandaleux
au nom de la liberté d'expression de
poursuivre une personne pour vous pour
cela et là ô mon avis il ya vraiment
quelque chose qui sort du domaine de la
justice pour être purement politique
avez vous envie de défendre les jurés à
mon jeu je vais signer ce rôle parce que
j'y crois profondément je pense que la
justice manque de moyens elle est
attaquée de toutes parts qu'est-ce qu'on
n'a pas entendu sur la justice pendant
la campagne présidentielle de 2017 la
droite et l'extrême droite extrême
gauche tout le monde à taper sur le ps
qu'on fasse on était inexistant donc il
risquait pas de papiers sur la justice
mêlé tous les autres l'ont tous les
autres l'ont fait et ce n'est pas
acceptable parce que dans une démocratie
saine moderne on doit avoir des contre
pouvoirs forts des médias forme aussi
des juges force à tapas plus à droite
qu'à gauche
oh non je peux ce sentiment là quand
vous dire que je ne veux pas vous faire
le descriptif du quinquennat de françois
hollande parce que ce serait pas à
l'honneur des gens qui ont travaillé à
ses côtés mais montre cahuzac qui a été
condamné en appel
bruno le roux qui a fait l'objet d'une
pré d'enquêté préliminaire kader arif
qui a été nommé au pkk est préliminaire
hakim nos morel qui a fait l'objet d'une
enquête préliminaire qui a eu un non
lieu faouzi lamdaoui répond c'est pas
mal
des affaires judiciaires les 90% de ces
affaires se sont terminées par des
non-lieux c'est le cas notamment des
killing au moral et et et bien d'autres
on a toujours laisser la justice
travailler et on en a tiré les
conséquences extrêmement rapidement je
pense que c'était parti de dieu bon
fonctionnement démocratique je
préférerai toujours trop de justice est
trop d'indépendance de la justice plutôt
que passer de justice et les juges sur
lequel on tire au sens figuré du terme
naturellement on réagira mais en
français moi je pense qu'effectivement
il faut avoir de l'indépendance de la
justice et je pense qu'il faut
effectivement la soutenir et elle
devrait avoir beaucoup plus de moyens
dire je suis favorable à ce que l'état
renforce ses actions régaliennes et ses
ministères régaliens et arrêtent et bien
je tombe sur la tête du registre est
aujourd'hui connue comme la monarchie de
juillet voilà et d'anglais en revanche
avec à peu près deux ou trois fois plus
de français
3 voilà je mets qui est en revanche
beaucoup moins d'étapes a pas d'état
social avec plus de la moitié de la
richesse nationale qui va dans les mains
de la décision publique
donc ça je suis tout à fait pour
l'indépendance de la justice et le
renforcement de la justice
en revanche je suis aussi pour la
séparation des pouvoirs là il me semble
que la justice empiète sur empiète sur
le politique
je n'ai pas souvenir de marine le pen
disant de jus ce qu'ils étaient fous là
y'a juste qu'ils demandent une expertise
psychiatrique
à l'évidence alors on peut évidemment
pas d'accord avec le programme avec des
opinions et même avec l'idéologie de
marine le pen
enfin
est clair que n'est pas folle je suis
tout à fait d'accord qu'il faut défendre
la liberté d'expression dans ce pays qui
est attaqué de toutes parts on en
parlera tout à l'heure avec la faire et
nous on peut très bien ne pas être
d'accord avec eric zemmour enfin que
avec zemmour qui exprime très bon
français puisse parler puisse s'exprimer
c'est un peu y répondre on en parle à
tout à l'heure et il est à 100 c'est
effectivement que marine le pen est été
condamné pour avoir diffusé ces images
alors qu'elle voulait simplement montrer
la sauvagerie de l'état islamique et
voulait montrer alors sur sur ces
histoires d'emplois fictifs
ça je ne peux pas du tout jugé parce que
je n'ai pas enquêté donc je ne n'ai
aucune idée là dessus
bon je je je remarque je ne sais pas
effectivement si les autres partis ont
été traités par le passé avec la
sévérité avec lequel est traité le front
national c'est assez curieux c'est plus
le front national est monté plus la
justice s'est prononcée contre elle
contre le front national
j'espère où le rassemblement national
maintenant j'espère que c'est fortuit
j'espère que ce débat politique parce
que je répète je suis vraiment pour une
séparation des pouvoirs la montesquiou
séparation des pouvoirs qui n'est
d'ailleurs pas acté non plus qu'il est
de moins en moins et est hélas aux états
unis d'amérique
c'est une autre et ça absolument gars
c't'un concerne la sphère de l'
expertise psychiatrique ça vous a pas
choqué non plus je connais pas le détail
pourquoi
quelles sont les motivations du juge
parce que la montage avec la justice et
l'état de droit c'est que toutes les
décisions de justice doivent être
motivées endroit et que si on les
conteste et bien on a discuté on en fait
rappelle donc si marine le pen
contestent cette expertise psychiatrique
elle peut en faire appel
dans le cas de la procédure demandé à
son avocat de la contester je ne crois
pas que ce soit un sujet de discussion
politique sur habits qu'on en discute ce
soir mais je crois pas que ce soit le ça
soit le cas il ya des procédures dans un
état de droit qui permettent de
contester des expertises sont demandés
c'est une procédure habituelle mais moi
ce qui me choque c'est que la personne
poursuivie en premier lieu pour repenser
pour ce délit là et qu'on ait choisi la
poursuivre et d'enclencher cette
procédure
après la procédure met en oeuvre en
effet les lecteurs une expertise
psychiatrique fait partie de la
procédure
mais dès le départ mon avis
il n'y avait pas un point de vue que
cette juste de séquence politique mais
pas sur soi une mauvaise séquence pour
elle parce que ça lui permet de se
positionner aussi en victime donc c'est
une m
voilà en tout cas ça lui mais là le site
et les rmistes est tout à fait clair
enfin faut dire les choses comme elles
sont
il est tout à fait clair pour mieux
imposer une expertise psychiatrique
quelque part je ne sais pas d'où mais le
système déraille c'est évident sophie
pouvez vous évoquer la mise en examen de
françois fillon pendant la campagne
présidentielle
avec le recul vous qui êtes une analyste
la vie politique vous trouvez que les
choses se sont passées comme elle le
devait ou est-ce que c'était trop
vraiment l époque j'étais jeu j'ai
exprimé une opinion qui se disaient peu
c'est à dire que j'étais moins attachés
à ce que à un moment donné il ya une
forme de sanctuarisation d'une d'une
campagne présidentielle pour une raison
très simple gaspard grandeur parlait de
non-lieu vous déclenchez aussi proche
d'une élection présidentielle qui comme
la seule élection provigent la seule
élection électorale oui enfin la seule
élection qui mobilise 80% des français
et à un moment donné si proche de
l'échéance vous déclenchez une affaire
ya rien de plus simple que de déclencher
une affaire enfin gaspard viens de citer
deux non lieux et donc vous bousculer
mais totalement la donne de départ et
vous le faites si proche d'une d'une
échéance donc moi j'étais plutôt à
l'époque pour dire attention il ya un
moment donné où il faut peut-être juste
faire une espèce de trêve on parce que
il ya une nécessité parce que déclencher
quelque chose pour arriver à un non lieu
vous remettez absolument tout par terre
vous changer la donne c'est pas anodin
c'est en ça que je dis que d'une
certaine manière d'éclat justice se
saisit d'une question politique
ll de elle devient une justice politique
parce que elle va transformer le jeu
politique quoi qu'il arrive
voilà évidemment je ne vais pas être
d'accord c'est déjà un parce que la
procédure judiciaire en cours contre
françois fillon qui toujours en cours
d'ailleurs lui n'a pas bénéficié de
non-lieux une l'a pas été c'est chiant
problème avec françois fillon c'est
qu'effectivement on pressentait quand
même une forme de cube et lens sochaux
qui n'a pas été empêché de se présenter
à l'élection présidentielle
lui même d'ailleurs a été si du sceau
idal sur le sujet puisque un premier
temps il avait dit que s'il était mis en
examen il serait plus candidat puis
finalement il
restez il a pu faire un score tout à
fait honorable il a fait un bon score la
présidentielle donc finalement la
justice l'a pas empêché de dockers des
voix qui nous morel la procédure était
tout à fait abusive fakih leno morel est
un grand serviteur de l'état un peu
d'accord pas d'accord avec françois
hollande mais c'est peut-être que c'est
clairement il a rien à faire en france
soir l'homme aimé élire un froid il
n'avait rien à se reprocher blessé c'est
incroyable que la justice autre chose à
faire que s'intéresser à et qui le moral
qui savent très bon et honnête servi toi
de les traquer de morale a été si c'est
nécessaire je ne sais pas à nouveau
remis comme il convenait aujourd'hui
quelques réactions d'internautes alors
yoann se demande
il y à une saisie de 2 millions plus une
expertise médicale et maintenant on rend
un million que signifie tout cela
j'espère que chagrine qu'on vous a
répondu parce que c'était justement
l'objet ce débat quant à anti mac sur
lefigaro.fr
il nous dit la décision d'un juge ne
doit pas dépendre ses opinions
effectivement c'est là le coeur du sujet
même si c'est parfois difficile de faire
une séparation stricte on passe à un
autre sujet les élections municipales
s'étendent 2020 c'est ça casse pas comme
ça alors on ne sait pas encore s'il vous
gâtera quand cette quantité à la mairie
de paris mais en tout cas il ya déjà
quelques candidats officiels à la
république en marche au moins deux
ministres benjamin griveaux et mounir
mahjoubi plus un député un sénateur
quelques autres qui hésite et s'il y
avait en plus peut-être pour les
départager
edouard philippe le premier ministre y
en a qui trouvent que ce serait une très
bonne idée
c'est cette grippe cédric villani le
député la république en marche de
l'essonne écoutez le je pense qu'il ya
eu des problèmes importants sur la
méthode qui justifie que la république
en marche présente un candidat contre
anitele à oignies gago qui serait le bon
profil on parle edouard philippe le
premier ministre est pour l'instant et
beaucoup de noms qui circulent trop
edward décidé de la solution
edouard philippe serait bien sûr un
grand maire de paris et j'en suis
persuadé il a déjà été un grand maire du
havre alors qu'à ce train là on a envie
de vous entendre edouard philippe ferait
il un bon maire de paris je ne sais pas
je ne sais pas quelles sont ses
intentions pour l'instant il a un job
important quand même
remplir ses gammes dès le premier
ministre je pense que ça doit suffire
quand même aller occuper totalement et
je pense qu'il est mauvais que un
premier ministre des ministres des
membres du gouvernement ou des députés
pensent déjà à la prochaine élection moi
j'avais quelque chose que j'ai bien aimé
dans l'élection à la mairie de macron
c'est la promesse du renouvellement
politique ait l'idée qu'on ferait la
politique autrement et je pense qu'une
des clés pour faire la politique
autrement c'est de se consacrer
totalement au mandat ou à la fonction
qu'on vous a désigné qu'elle est là
quelle plus belle fonction que premier
ministre de la france après près en
république ça devrait suffire au bonheur
d'edouard philippe et je suis certain
parce que j'ai beaucoup d'estimé pour
lui lorsque ans gérard collomb pour la
fonction de ministre de l'intérieur
parce qu'il a tort je pense qu'il a tort
je pense que gérard collomb devrait
rester à son poste jusqu'au bout là il
ya une menace terroriste importante il
faut que se consacrer pleinement à sa
tâche
on peut pas tout faire à la fois
ministre premier ministre est déjà un
beau job il faut se concentrer
totalement ils comptent quant aux
élections à la mairie de paris
je pense ça sera aux parisiennes et aux
parisiens d'en décider et oh vous savez
qu habituellement ils n'aiment pas trop
qu'on se sert de paris comme un
marchepied un tremplin une médaille
et il ya ceux qui ont été parachutés de
l'extérieur pour être conduit la mairie
de paris n'ont pas conservé des bons
souvenirs puisqu'il s'appelle d'ornano
séguin nkm joxe sont tous du essuyé une
sévère défaite
et bien voilà premier ministre prévenu
on vous pose la question à vous chers
internautes d'après vous edouard
philippe ferait il un bon maire pour la
ville de paris vous êtes 62% répondre
non à 38%
oui pour cherain sur twitter edouard
philippe à gérer la ville du havre c'est
une ville importante
ses compétences du prévenu qui serviront
beaucoup et edouard philippe remplit
toutes les conditions requises
bon bah celui là est fan de toute
évidence et vous anne sophie beauvais
non mais ça l'est pour le coup je suis
vraiment d'accord avec avec gaspar noé
heures je pense que edouard philippe a
effectivement les premiers mise de la
france et
il doit être consacré à sa tâche moi je
trouve ça quand même fou que deux ans
avant une élection on parle autant des
candidats potentiels à 7 à cette
élection et effectivement ils sont très
nombreux
renouvellement de la classe politique
oui en même temps ce renouvellement de
la classe politique
il ré avec un ancrage un petit peu plus
fort sur un terrain localement je trouve
que ce serait pas une mauvaise chose je
pense notamment aux députés élus
en marche parce que je moi j'étais pour
qu'on limite les mandats dans le temps
mais peut-être pas qu'on déconnecte
complètement le mandat de député avec
celui de maire parce que je pense qu'on
apprend beaucoup d'un territoire et que
d'une certaine manière que certains
députés et un ancrage local un petit peu
plus important je serai plus que nos
ministres qui effectivement est une
tâche lourde après pour la mairie de
paris
moi je suis banlieusarde et donc j'avoue
que si on pouvait avoir un futur maire
de paris qui n'est pas une vision
égoïste de paris mais qu'il à tourner un
peu vers la banlieue je suis pas valérie
pécresse par exemple aujourd'hui un
discours en tout cas qui réconcilie un
petit peu les banlieusards avec paris je
regarde mon partenaire de noyon saison
passée ce message je suis votre droite
une pas votre gauche mais le je suis
très attaché à ces questions je pense
que le prochain maire de paris doit être
le maire du grand paris tout simplement
alors il ya quelqu'un une autre personne
qui serait assez favorable à la
candidature d'edouard philippe c'est un
hamac l'essayiste qui nous les
interviews et voilà donc un hamac sera
donc interviewé dans le figaro demain et
je vous l'annonçais en avant première il
considère qu' edouard philippe serait le
meilleur candidat pour paris d'autant
ajoute-t-il qui serait capable de faire
alliance avec la droite modérée gêné
bastié votre avis sur ce sujet oui je
sais c'est significatif qu il ya autant
de gens dans le gouvernement vaincrons
qui veulent devenir maire de paris ça
veut dire beaucoup de choses aussi sur
ce qu'est le maquereau nice puisque on
pourrait presque mettre une égalité
entre macro nice mais paris puisque mais
le maquereau a fait 90 % à la
présidentielle au 2e tour à paris
et c'est quand même la fin qu'on dit je
parle de paris un pas de paris et sa
banlieue mais paris c'est quand même la
ville de composer plutôt d'une
bourgeoisie soit libéral soit de droite
ou de gauche qui s'est réconcilié dans
le maquereau nisme et voilà par baril si
paris est aussi le symbole de cela et
donc je pense que n'importe quel
candidat dans marche n'aurait aucune
difficulté à gagner paris
même si évidemment il y a
il ya une particularité à paris c'est
que c'est comme aux états unis
enfin on peut avoir on peut ne pas avoir
la majorité des voix mais gagner quand
même la mairie taille puisque ce sont
les arrondissements finalement enfin
c'est quand on me dira celluloïd ordis
mans qui choisissent le maire de paris
donc ça peut être comme aux états unis
on peut on faire basculer les
arrondissements qui ont fait basculer
les étapes pour regagner paris donc ça
change un peu la donne
mais cela dit je crois que en marche à
un tapis rouge à paris si vous gagnez la
presle à la mairie alors vous le disiez
il ya beaucoup de candidats en marche
mais il y en a aussi pas mal ailleurs
même marché le campion et candidat à la
mairie de paris
et pour cause parce que ce job tout le
monde en rêve c'est en tout cas la
conviction de rachida dati qui est maire
du 7e arrondissement et qui était invité
ce matin de notre ami yves très rare
dans le talk du figaro
aujourd'hui quel est l'élu paris qui ne
rêve pas du mandat de maire de paris
tous celui qui vous dit le nom il ment
parce que c'est un très beau mandat
c'est la plus belle ville du monde moi
je considère il ya beaucoup d'enjeu et
des enjeux très intéressant comme ça
tout le monde en rêve même vous moi je
ne rêve pas pour moi je rêve de parler
depuis toujours donc pas besoin d'être
un émérite paris pour continuer à rêver
cette ville mais je pense que c'est
surtout les paris ce sont surtout les
parisiennes et les parisiens qui ont
envie de rêver de nouveau de leur ville
ils sont contents qu'on comme de
sécurité de propreté de logement de
transport et surtout peut-être que leur
vie de bree moins dans le monde
les artistes du monde entier ne se bat
plus pour venir à paris comme à l'époque
d'hemingway et c'est bien dommage
les entreprises du monde entier ne se
bat plus pour venir à paris c'est bien
dommage et c'est ça qu'il faut retrouver
notamment renaud girard fait nous le
portrait robot du meilleur maire de
paris en tout cas c'est pas selon moi
edouard philippe pas qu'il n'ait pas pas
qu'il en ait pas les capacités
on a certainement les capacités et
peut-être même le goût mais qui je pense
qu'il doit préférer le havre puisqu'on a
été maire mais jo c'est assez grave
comme signe des temps si vous voulez il
nous a annoncé enfin emmanuel macron et
lui nous on annonce il a fait appeler un
discours de politique générale 1
edouard philippe il a voilà et le
gouvernement dit la constitution
détermine et conduit la politique de la
nation
article 20 de la constitution alors il
nous il a dit qu'il allait réformer le
pays
on attend on attend edouard philippe
pour le moment il a fait un budget
extrêmement timide extrêmement mou sans
vouloir déplaire à gaspard extrêmement
hollandais mais voilà et a pris du recul
tient pas de problème aux landais voilà
alors pas du tout dans la ligne de ce
qu'on nous avait annoncé alors je pense
je pense que ça serait ça serait dingue
il a il a une tâche a fait alors on dit
il prend son temps il veut prendre son
temps c'est très bien mais en tout cas
on lui donne cinq ans pour vraiment
réformer la france on espère que quand
il rendra son tablier deux premiers
ministres et un tablier
n'est ce pas dire extrêmement important
en l'occurrence plus important que celui
de maire de paris
et bien qu'ils nous donnent une france
en bien meilleur état qu'il l'a trouvé
je pense qu'il faut qui continue son
travail il allait avec un premier
ministre tout à fait compétent alors
après en politique c'est comme pour le
président mâcon c'est la volonté qui
conseille à l'intelligence et à la
connaissance de l'administration et
après il ya le vent t il ya le courage
pour le moment ils en ont montré un peu
pas énormément on les attend mais mais
mais cette espèce de zapping dans les
fonctions politiques et dangereux et je
dirais même un drame de notre démocratie
de notre pays
deux réactions d'internautes à ces
critiques vincent qui trouvent que le
premier ministre a déjà suffisamment
abîmé le havre et la france quant à j lr
il considère qu' edouard philippe s'est
déjà mis la majorité des français à dos
avec le 80 km heure c'est un argument
qui revient souvent quand on parle de
voir philippe impossible qu'il soit élu
maire de la capitale nous affirme jlr
jeudi bastié oui alors moi je pense que
c'est pas difficile de faire mieux kidal
goûts en matière de propreté de sécurité
et d'entretien du patrimoine à paris
par contre et ça je pense que quelqu'un
en marche en tout cas sera plus
pragmatique
en revanche il ya une question qui est
un vrai problème à paris
c'est l'action la mixité sociale et du
prix du logement qui s'envole et si
c'est pour faire de paris encore plus la
capitale des csp + et finalement ne rien
faire pour lutter par exemple contre la
propagation d'airbnb parce que voilà en
marche c'est aussi sont les héros de la
libéralisation de l'économie mais si on
ne fait rien contre
airbnb contre le fait que finalement on
a vu l'a récemment qu' il ya plus de
milliardaires aujourd'hui à paris qu'il
y en a à londres après brique site
si si enfin si le seul but c'est de
faire de paris une capitale attractive
pour les capitaux et donc pour les
millionnaires moi je trouve que c'est
pas suffisant pour les parisiens parce
que s'il ya quand même une un enjeu de
mixité sociale à paris qui devient très
problématique puisque à part certains
quartiers nord où il ya une très forte
immigration il n'y a plus de classes
populaires à paris il n'ya plus même
plus de classes moyennes à paris
il n'y a plus de famille et je trouve
que c'est un enjeu très important
vous savez moi j'ai je suis père de
quatre enfants et je peux dire que c'est
un exploit pour les familles que l'on
croise dans paris de rester dans paris
un cadre je vais totalement dans le sens
de ce que je dis mais pas ce que
vraiment il faut qu'on se batte pour qui
les classes populaires
qu'est-ce qu'on a une qui reste lens et
lille et que ça devienne pas la ville de
la spéculation immobilière comme elle
l'est aujourd'hui par exemple moi je
suis pas du tout sûr que ce soit une
bonne idée qu'on se bat pour que tous
les anglais ou les financiers qui sont à
la city revient à paris pour faire
exploser les prix du mobilier je pense
que non mais c'est un mais qu'est ce que
c'est ce qui est en train de se passer
notamment avec moi j'ai pas du tout
envie que les londoniens restent à
londres vraiment il ya je ne souhaite
pas du tout qui y viennent nous faire
monter les prix partout dans paris
il faut construire des logements sociaux
conçoit des logements intermédiaires
évidemment réguler extrêmement fortement
les herbes emba consoeurs qui font
exploser les prix de l'immobilier aussi
à l'achat comme à la vente et même à la
location et puis certainement aussi
construit une politique du logement
intelligente à l'échelle de new man
paris nord on parlait tout à l'heure
parce que cette ville est beaucoup trop
petit on est une ville qui est cernée
par son périphérique et qui à moins de 5
km de son centre
c'est la ville la plus petite du monde
dans les grandes capitales il suffit
d'aller à madrid à berlin à rome à
l'ombre à tokyo je prends même pas tokyo
new york ça pour se rendre compte qu'on
est une ville minuscule et c'est la
source de beaucoup de nos problèmes
anne-sophie pauvres on raisonne là
depuis quelques minutes comme s'ils
allaient d'algos n'allait pas être
réduits et pourtant il lui reste en fait
en tout cas c'est ce qu'on dira un socle
électoral réel
malgré toutes ces critiques ça ça vous
surprendre oui et puis enfin et puis lui
reste surtout deux ans moi je me mets à
sa place d'une certaine manière
deux ans est encore long quand même à
l'échelle d'une ville et donc je me pose
des questions sur sa capacité
j'allais dire à faire que pendant ces
deux ans des décisions puissent être
encore prises dans de bonnes conditions
avec cette effervescence autour de la
maire de paris moi je partage pas du
tout là
enfin jaillir la vision de la maire de
paris pour ça pour sa ville et je le
redis je trouve qu'il ya eu un problème
d'abord de un peu d'enfermement de paris
sur elle même par rapport à la par
rapport à la banlieue je pense qu'il ya
eu aussi un problème de méthode puisque
elle décide de fermer par exemple les
voies sur berge sans concertation une
concertation qui est enclenchée après
coup et que ça a provoqué quand même bon
nombre de problèmes notamment sur ses
périphériques le gaspard grandeur veut
supprimer mais pour le moment c'est
quand même là où la circulation a été a
été repoussé et puis toutes ces voix en
30 sur paris qui sont aujourd'hui
complètement bouché mais malgré tout ce
que je lui reconnais c'est une vision
pour la ville de paris c'est à dire
qu'elle est on a tendance à l'oublier
quand même aussi un tout petit peu on
lui tape dessus tous comme des sous
verres elle a une vraie vision une
vision écologique pour ça pour sa ville
donc et elle a essayé avec courage
malgré tout parce que vu son niveau
d'impopularité on veut pas lui dénier sa
de la m de la mettre en oeuvre
voilà ne l'a pas eu mais c'est une
vision malgré tout qui ce qui peut se
défendre elle un cap
voilà le paradoxe est en commun le
paradoxe étant quand même qu'on a
reporté donc la pollution sur le
périphérique et vous savez d'endroit
plus polluées de paris le métro
donc il ya comme un petit problème c'est
que quand on construit une politique
contre la pollution pour l'environnement
ce qui est très juste et ce qu'il faut
faire il faut le faire de façon
cohérente avec la bonne méthode alors on
passe assure qu'il n'a rien à voir son
confrère eric zemmour a sorti un livre
il a aussi été au coeur d'une polémique
vous avez peut-être suivi pour savoir si
les
et familles issues de l'immigration
devait donner des prénoms français à
leurs enfants
suite aux nombreux remous qui ont
entouré cette polémique le patron de
l'émission on n'est pas couché sur
france 2 laurent ruquier a décidé de ne
pas inviter eric zemmour tout en disant
qu' il n'avait jamais été formellement
programmée alors est ce que c'est la
bonne décision après tout s'il n'est pas
d'accord avec les idées de zemmour il
n'invite pas même si zemmour a été son
chroniqueur pendant cinq ans en tout cas
c'est pas la vie d'un autre journaliste
et animateur ali baddou qui est
journaliste à france inter qui a invité
lui eric zemmour et qui ne le regrette
pas écoutez moi j'assume complètement ce
choix vous leur ferez pourquoi pas une
émission de débat c'est fait pour
installer un dialogue entre des gens qui
ne sont pas d'accord
sinon ça s'appelle pas un débat et puis
refusé de débattre s'est s'incliné donc
en l'occurrence recevoir eric zemmour il
ya été face à natacha polony raphaël
glucksmann qui lui ont apporté la
contradiction qui n'ont absolument rien
lâché qui ont tenu pied à pied
c'était intéressant et on a même appris
des choses on a appris des choses en
tout cas moi je trouve que c'était une
émission utile
rené girard est ce que laurent récré
doit inviter ses mots aussi là pour en
vue c'est son droit
d'abord je crois que ali baddou a
parfaitement raison et puis alors je ne
sais pas exactement
ah oui un bond à zemmour n'est pas là le
titre n est pas propriétaire de france 2
est donc de cette émission et donc n'a
pas droit à participer à cette émission
si en revanche c'est sur la pression
d'un lynchage médiatique que ruquier
retire cette invention a lassé grave
parce que je suis favorable
personnellement à la liberté
d'expression
eric zemmour dit que les
parents issus de l'immigration devrait
donner des prénoms français à leurs
enfants repas michele platini mais
michel platini c'est son opinion
on peut être d'accord ou pas d'accord
est-ce que absatou est une insulte à la
france personnellement je le pense je
pense pas que ce prénom le nom va là
d'une autre personne d'une hausse de fès
des classiques et qu'il a dit mais enfin
et c'est vraiment là dit voilà je pense
qu'elle a été elle était mais je pense
que ces mots a tout à fait le droit de
dire ça elle a même dit à la personne
vous devriez vous appeliez corinne on
c'est un style voilà mais voulait donner
de l'animation alors on peut tout à fait
ne pas être d'accord avec lui on peut
tout à fait faire penser que ce qui est
plus important et une valeur française
effectivement cette intégration et moi
je pense que zemmour a des intentions
pures gillet assimilationniste et la
raison est là et lui-même sa famille a
montré désir d'assimiler d'assimilation
mais il a parfois des excès de langage
on peut dire que il n'a peut-être plus
vexé c'est hapsatou sy on vous devrez
vous appelez corinne et puis on peut
aussi penser qu' il ya une autre valeur
française alors il a tout à fait raison
sur la simulation zemmour mais nous de
valeur pour penser qu'il nous valeurs
qui peut-être plus importante sur ce
prénom qu'il valeurs françaises de
liberté on peut dire que ben on
considère que c'est plus important
message est légalement mais voilà mais
je suis ce que zemmour
j'ai moore il faut l'écouter et que ce
serait grave pour la liberté
d'expression en france qu' il n'est pas
le droit de débattre merci renaud girard
anne sophie boguet quel est votre point
de vue sur ce sujet oui ça fait du bien
effectivement d'entendre ali baddou le
dire parce que je trouve que ce qui
serait aussi une insulte pour la france
ce serait que ce débat ne puisse pas
avoir lieu parce qu'il ya un vrai débat
effectivement sur cette question de
de l'assimilation et j'espère qu'on peut
dire sans s'en prendre plein la figure
que un prénom c'est effectivement qui
est un des éléments d'une assimilation
loin d'être le seul en tout cas c'est un
des éléments si je peux juste me
permettre de raconter une anecdote
familiale moi j'ai des grands parents de
chaque côté qui sont qui sont immigrés
polonais d'un côté italien de l'autre
mes grands parents polonais ont choisi
de donner un prénom polonais donc à ma
mère qui sait qu'il ya donc eu un prénom
polonais et un nom de famille polonaise
dwdm absolument partout qui a eu
beaucoup de mal avec ce prénom est ce
nom de famille mais elle en a eu aussi
beaucoup de mal parce qu'en fait pour
elle elle était née en france et elle
était française est en fait elle a
toujours souhaité porter un prénom
français et ça fait partie de sa
démarche d'assimilation que de basculer
j'allais dire sur un prénom français et
je ne sais pas si vous le savez mais la
loi a été simplifié quelques temps sur
le sujet c'est à dire qu'on a autorisé à
faire ces demandes-là en mairie et non
plus devant le juge aux affaires
familiales et ma mère qui a 70 ans donc
elle a un âge avancé a fait cette
démarche
voilà donc ça fait partie de sa démarche
de citoyenneté en tout cas de
l'assimilation de notre propre famille
sur le territoire donc j'allais dire que
ce débat puisse être posée et qu'on
puisse la voir entre nous je trouve ça
bon maintenant le style d'eric zemmour
on le connaît c'est une espèce de sabre
ça ça ça vient c'est assez c'est assez
violent effectivement donc mais il était
face à des chroniqueurs qui sont là pour
lui répondre et je pense qu ali baddou a
raison en tout cas si on souhaite lui
répondre il faut pouvoir le faire note
achats paul o'neill affaire a fait plus
de semaine l'a fait et juste pour
terminer si moi je pense qu'un prénom si
on veut un garde et un prénom étrangers
cite aussi tout à fait quelque chose de
possible parce qu'on témoigne d'une
filiation à sa famille voilà c'est une
possibilité comme vous le disait qu'il
doit être laissée mais en tout cas ce
débat là méritent d'être posées sans
crispation et sans lynchage merci de
deux points de vue de nos internautes
d'autant plus intéressant que qu'ils
sont contraires yoran pense que ruquier
doit tout à zemmour et qui ne devrait
pas l'écarter comme cela soudainement
allusion sans doute au buzz que faisait
mots quand il était chroniqueur dans
l'émission tandis que amir sur
lefigaro.fr nous dit mais si on refuse
d'accueillir soral dieudonné et c'est
pourquoi
zemmour se retrouver sur un plateau de
télévision n'est plus un droit
aujourd'hui
gaspard ganzer votre point de vue mais
évidemment je suis attaché à la liberté
d'expression et tout le monde a le droit
d'exprimer ses opinions mais j'ai plutôt
le sentiment inverse je pense qu'eric
zemmour est totalement abonnés des
plateaux télé des micros de radio et des
colonnes de journaux depuis longtemps on
n'entend que lui tout temps sur tous les
sujets pour répéter à peu près toujours
la même chose l'histoire du président
n'était pas du tout la première fois
qu'il qui la faisait tourner en boucle
moi je trouve ça je suis pas d'accord
avec lui sur le fond mais c'est là c'est
comme ça je l'approuverai sur rien mais
bon ça c'est comme ça j'ai pas du tout
sentiment qu'ils soient privés de parole
j'ai donc non mais je lis ça je dis cela
je lui suis fabriqué mart ou non je suis
vraiment désolé je se victimise non
habitée en permanence ses services et à
un seul but à la télé ils s'invitent à
la télé pour dire on cherche à me priver
de ma parole non il n'a jamais dit ça
quand est ce qu'elle a dit ça mais il
était encore il ya deux jours j'ai
entendu à la radio dire exactement est
ce que c'est vrai que les gens demain il
ya une pétition ceux qui s'y
refuseraient de signer par exemple une
personne dont kg mais là il le fait
parce qu en effet là on vit le fait on
lui demande il le fait paul donc site
c'est une vérité objective on demande
d'abord pu inviter la télé donc 60 ans
team sebah la limitation ses bienfaits
se disent pas une fille victime ismail
prisonnier le plus c'est que je sais
c'est qu'il ya des victimes et des
menaces de mort mais les procureurs dans
paris
mais rien n'est pas une victime je
combats c'est l'idée il ya un autre truc
qui m'a vraiment profondément choqué
c'est ce qu'il a dit sur route rodin
c'est le cet intellectuel communiste ce
mathématicien
on y était pro algérien membre du pilori
mérité douce pau 12 balles dans la peau
at-il dit jour là bas skoda il faut dire
aussi pourquoi dans cinq régions du haut
d'un était il faut dire que c'est un bon
mathématicien était aussi je crois
porteurs de valises c'est à dire qu'il a
du mal à se faire il finançait à bah
voilà alors est-ce qu'il financerait un
débat bien aujourd'hui ça y est ce
qu'ils finançaient ou pas est-ce qu'elle
finance et ou pas il se trouve qu'on
était en guerre contre en algérie
général de gaulle selon moi eu tout à
fait raison d'être fatigué il a dit
mourad et 12 balles dans la peau parce
que ils pensent que odin aider l'ennemi
on her in an sans voix les rssi beaucoup
j'ai dit bastien est ce que le fait que
laurent ruquier soit animateur d'une
émission de télévision sur le service
public lui lui donne une situation
particulière ou des devoirs particuliers
ou bien donc à aucun devoir ami d'eric
zemmour et d'ailleurs il était invité
sur france inter sur le service public
il n'y a pas de voie et je comprends que
que le hockey n'est pas envie de
l'inviter simplement il avait décommandé
sous pression médiatique qui me semble
un manque d'élégance et de courage il
avait effectivement en premier lieu
décidé d'inviter eric zemmour suite à la
polémique et moi je trouve ça inquiétant
parce que on est passé d'un discours
eric zemmour n'a pas droit de parler
dénoncé eric zemmour au discours de
dénoncer les médias qu'il invite
maintenant le procès s'est on attaque
ardisson on attaque les médias qui font
parler eric zemmour ces news les bolloré
et compagnie alors que c'est quand même
le rôle des médias de faire parler d
il est jamais tout seul pendant une
heure à parler tout seul est toujours
des contradicteurs face à lui on ne
donne jamais le micro seul et je trouve
c'est le rôle du débat c'est d'inviter
des contradicteurs et ce procès qui est
fait aux médias qui invite eric zemmour
je le trouve extrêmement dangereux et
c'est pour ça et d'ailleurs j'en étais
sûr quand j'ai vu la polémique montée
j'étais sûr que vous qui allez arrêter
de l'invité et enfin le désinvité et
c'est bien bien sûr arriver merci
beaucoup à tous les cas tu vas
participer à cette émission que j'ai
tout fait pour ma part passionnante mais
j'avoue que je suis pas très objectif
donc c'est à vous d'en juger chers
internautes merci beaucoup et à demain
même heure même endroit pour un nouveau
point de vue bonne soirée
[Musique]
à